hey so listen this is not the most
important story
but we all need a little comedic relief
every once in a while
and last night on tucker carlson's fox
news show
guest after guest lost their connection
and i don't know why
but i just found it hilarious i think
part of it is the look on tucker
carlson's face every time his guests
would lose connection now
i want to be really really clear texas
is having power outages right now
one of the guests who loses their
internet connection
is former republican governor rick perry
and tucker carlson mentions him being in
texas now i don't know if the storms are
actually the reason rick perry loses
internet
and all of his guests even the ones not
in texas were losing connection
so it may have nothing to do but we are
not
making light of what is happening in
texas right now people without power
okay that's not what this is about
i think what's funny is tucker doing his
confused face
every time it happens so if you're only
listening that will be an element that
you won't be able to
observe unless you take a look at the
video versions of this but let's jump
right into it
here is former texas governor former
trump
administration secretary of energy rick
perry
losing his connection and tucker tries
to at least blame it on rick's
connection although i doubt whether
that's what's going on let's take a look
so i i love texas
don't want to attack texas on the other
hand the most basic responsibility of
government you'd think is to keep the
power on especially when people needed
to survive they didn't why
hmm
i should say that rick perry is in texas
it sounded like he was in space but he's
not he's in texas he has no power
that's being run i think on a generator
he's proving the point that we're making
governor we're going to put you on hold
for a second to see if we can get the
power back on
in your state okay so maybe it's the
storms there
but then in comes florida governor
ron desantis a republican governor
who was going on tucker's show to brag
about how
they're just opening it wide open in
florida
uh regardless of the virus and he loses
his connection now at this point
you can't blame the power outages in
texas
for ron desantis losing his connection
can you take a look
ever says that out loud i mean how could
you ignore
something that the data show
oh i'm afraid we've lost governor
desantis
can you hear me governor i can't hear
oh i'm sorry about that i can hear the
governor he cannot hear me i just want
to say for the record that unlike us in
texas tonight
i think the power is still on in florida
fewer windmills uh in the state than
there are in texas so
that's the good news but for some reason
the governor couldn't hear us
we'll be back in just a moment a lot
going on i i was having a grand old time
re-watching these this morning it's also
very
poetic that a connection was lost
because these are two people rick perry
and ron desantis
who lost their connections with reality
a long time ago and i would actually
argue
that this was ron desantis's best public
statement ever just losing his
connection and
being unable to say anything he came off
looking way better than he normally does
when he's able to speak and notice
tucker carlson
throwing in a dig at wind farms there
sort of laughing at windmills and i
think the idea there
is that tucker wants to frame anybody
relying on wind farms can't possibly be
keeping the power on
compared to burning fossil fuels which i
guess is seen as
manly and alpha among the american right
no opportunity to attack clean energy
that tucker carlson won't avail himself
of and i mean listen being texas i'd
almost expect tucker to blame the power
outages or the loss of connection
on some migrant caravan approaching the
border which seems to be a catch-all
anytime they need to
blame anybody for anything maybe even
antifa but
uh many tech problems happening on
tucker carlson's program last night i
don't know why
i was laughing to myself this morning
just really really got a kick out of
that one
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed
that it's only using about half as much
water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
but the first hundred people who go to
nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get
15 off all nebia products the link
is underneath this video